bonsoir à tous lorsqu'on m'a demandé
pour la première fois de réaliser ce
tadic ce dans le cadre des nouveaux
explorateurs
moi qui ne suis pas un skipper ou
quelqu'un qui a particulièrement le
l'habitude d'être un explorateur
justement je me suis demandé comment on
peut être un explorateur au 21ème siècle
sachant que l'intégralité du globe et
maintenant cartographier qu'on peut
simplement de son canapé se déplacer
intégralement sur la planète pouvoir
même allé sur le sol lunaire où le sol
de mars
j'étais un petit peu frustré mais
heureusement il reste un territoire un
territoire inexploré ce territoire c'est
celui du cerveau alors c'est pas le mien
mais plutôt joli moi je trouve mais bon
ce territoire inexploré
c'est celui des neurosciences alors
aujourd'hui il ya une véritable
effervescence autour des neurosciences
des dans les écoles d'architecturé de
design on peut avoir des formations en
neurosciences dans la publicité
maintenant on utilise les résultats des
neurosciences afin de pouvoir augmenter
la performance des campagnes c'est ce
qu'on appelle le neuromarketing alors
pourquoi
et bien parce que les neurosciences
parmi ce qu'il ya de fascinant et
neurosciences c'est qu'elle explore les
mécanismes inconscients de notre cerveau
ces mécanismes qui en fait représentent
la majorité des processus mentaux
c'est un petit peu la partie immergée de
l'iceberg
et lorsqu'on veut aller étudier en
profondeur le cerveau et lorsqu'on veut
aller le plus en plus en profondeur dans
l'océan mais on va pas le faire en apnée
même si vous le verrez il ya peut-être
des exceptions tout à l'heure on utilise
un scaphandre voilà et nous on euros six
ans on n'a pas de scaphandres mais on à
l'imagerie cérébrale
alors voilà un exemple là c'est un autre
explorateur qui s'appelle vincent ricard
mathieu ricard excusez moi vincent là
car c'est quelqu'un de mon équipe n'a
rien à voir
mais ils ont le même nom aucun aucun
rapport mais tous les deux d'ailleurs
s'amuse à porter des capteurs sur la
tête là c'est pour le bien d'une
expérience scientifique
évidemment c'est réalisé dans un milieu
très contrôlée qui est le laboratoire
scientifique dans un hôpital
donc ça permet de mesurer l'activité du
cerveau mais voilà c'est un petit peu
limité est ce que nous a appris
l'imagerie cérébrale de manière générale
et bien c'est notre cerveau en fait
c'est un petit peu comme de la pâte à
modeler alors pourquoi parce que le
cerveau il est malléable le cerveau il
change il s'adapte quand vous êtes né
vous ne saviez ni parler ni même voir ni
même en temps en direct votre cerveau a
appris à le faire alors j'ai une très
bonne nouvelle pour vue c'est que
aujourd'hui on n'a plus besoin ni de
partir dans un laboratoire de recherche
et se barder la tête de capteurs ni de
partir en himalaya et de se raser la
tête pour devenir moine bouddhiste même
si ça doit être expérience géniale et
maintenant ces technologies
d'entraînement cérébral et d'exploration
du cerveau est bien le sont disponibles
à tous
c'est pas la longue vue que je cherchais
c'est ce casque est un exemple de ce
type d'outil qui en fait très facilement
va pouvoir vous permettre de mesurer
votre activité cérébrale et de devenir
vous même tous ici qu'est dans cette
salle des nouveaux explorateurs les
nouveaux explorateurs de votre propre
esprit alors très simplement
l'entraînement cérébral comment ça
marche bien c'est exactement le même
principe que lorsque on entraîne son
coup droit au tennis ou lorsqu'on
travaille les arpèges de piano alors
prenons l'exemple de rodger federer qui
est connu pour sa technicité
enfin moi j'en ça je connais pas du tout
le tennis mais bon on m'a dit qu'il
était parti que j'ai comparé que nadal
il paraît que c'est mieux alors comment
il fait pour entraîner son mouvement au
tennis et bien il arrive pour deux
raisons parce qu'il a une prise de
conscience il a une répétition du
mouvement il arrive à entraîner son
mouvement parce que il s'en est il voit
comment se déplace son bras pareil en
piano on arrive à améliorer parce qu'on
entend et on
et on arrive à voir ce qu'on fait sur le
piano et bien c'est pareil si on veut
entraîner son cerveau sauf que comme il
s'agit de mécanismes inconscients mais
il faut qu'on arrive à trouver un moyen
pour entendre ou voir ce qui se passe de
façon inconsciente dans notre cerveau et
c'est exactement ce que va faire ce type
d'appareil maintenant vous pouvez
littéralement connecter votre cerveau à
un smartphone ou un ordinateur et
pouvoir voir ou entendre les mécanismes
inconscients de votre cerveau prenons un
exemple avec ce casque par exemple vous
le mettez sur vos têtes là c'est marthe
à elle travaille dans le bureau en face
du mien et on lui a mis le cap sur la
tête on l'a pris en photo avec des
écouteurs parce qu'en fait la ce qu'elle
est en train de faire c'est de
littéralement entendre une musique qui
varient en fonction de son activité
cérébrale et ça ça lui permet de pouvoir
apprendre à se relaxer et à mieux gérer
son stress et on sait que le stress
c'est vraiment un problème qui nous
pourrit la vie au quotidien
d'autres exemples prenons par exemple
cet enfant cet enfant il est sujet à des
troubles de l'attention et
d'hyperactivité
il a donc un traitement médicamenteux
qui est assez lourd qui s'appelle la
ritaline est grâce à ces nouvelles
technologies qui permettent aux
personnes d'explorer leur activité
cérébrale
eh bien il arrive à contrôler les
mouvements d'un avion sur un écran par
la pensée est comme ça il entraîne sa
capacité à se concentrer et en étant
plus à même de se concentrer plus
facilement grâce à des séances répétées
et bien il arrive comme ça a diminué son
traitement médicamenteux
un autre exemple c'était au mondial à la
coupe du monde de football au brésil et
bien en 2014
un jeune homme paraplégique paralysé des
jambes a réussi à donner le coup d'envoi
de la coupe du monde
en contrôlant par la pensée un
exosquelette alors c'était juste un
petit un petit par le le ballon a fait
remettre il n'est pas il s'est pas mis à
courir autour du stade dans un triple
salto
mais ça c'est quand même le signe que ce
n'est que le début le début d'un d'une
nouvelle d'un nouveau continent qui va
être celui de l'exploration et de la
connexion de notre cerveau aux machines
mais également à nous mêmes
et si on allait un petit peu plus loin
si on part du principe que maintenant on
peut améliorer sa concentration
améliorer sa relaxation
peut-être que demain on pourra améliorer
l'ensemble de nos facultés
intellectuelles
peut-être notre mémoire notre sommeil
notre de calculs mentaux qui c'est notre
empathie
peut-être qu'on pourra arriver comme ça
a entraîné à améliorer notre capacité à
vivre ensemble et à mieux se comprendre
et puis si on connecte tous nos cerveaux
ordinateurs et aux smartphones
eh bien peut-être qu'un jour on formera
une sorte de grands réseaux de cerveaux
connectés alors ça peut paraître de la
science fiction mais c'est quelque chose
qui pourrait être imaginée
tous ces cerveaux connectés les uns aux
autres qui ont respectivement accès à
l'inconscient les uns des autres
est-ce que ça va améliorer la
communication et ça peut aussi apporter
beaucoup de questions aussi bien morale
qu'éthique est ce que il y aura
quelqu'un qui va sécuriser ce réseau
qu'est ce qui va se passer sur le pirate
moi j'ai pas envie de vous faire peur ce
soir c'est pas mon objectif
j'ai plutôt envie de vous dire ce que
j'ai envie de vous transmettre c'est que
on démarre une nouvelle ère une ère où
les neurosciences on faire partie de
notre quotidien
au même titre qu aujourd'hui la micro
informatique électronique font déjà
partie de notre quotidien et il ya des
gens qui travaillent alors il travaille
dans mon entreprise mais travaillent
dans d'autres laboratoires dans d'autres
entreprises et commence à développer des
nouvelles technologies et si c'est pas
vous qui décidez vous même de prendre le
pouvoir sur cette exploration du cerveau
d'un peut-être qu'il y a des gens qui
vont le faire à votre place
j'espère pas et c'est pourquoi on doit
tous aujourd'hui de façon collective
prendre la décision ensemble de prendre
le pouvoir sur ces technologies qui sont
disponibles pour tous et de commencer à
explorer son propre cerveau de partir
ensemble dans cette nouvelle aventure
qui est une aventure à la fois
intérieure puisque c'est quand même
intimité de notre esprit mais également
collective et cette aventure je vous
invite à la faire avec moi et ensemble
étape par étape à explorer le
le cerveau humain merci à vous merci